in my book I deal right away with a
meaning of meaning because I knew I
would be attacked like a disturbed nest
of Hornets
by philosophers if I did not
and of course meaning has a number of
meanings but generally speaking after
you've gone past the basic religious
definition of meaning which is well of
course a divine creator is responsible
for the design and nature of humanity
and what else you want to know after you
get past that particular response then
the subject moves to meaning as history
that is essentially what are we and why
where do we come from
and this is part of meeting - where are
we most likely to be headed and I like
to suggest that in order to answer those
questions we cannot do it with religion
because every religion has or have a
religious faith rather has a different
creation story story of how the universe
and earth and people came into being
and every faith has its own special
accounts of supernatural events and they
differ one from the other and they are
in competition and in any case the book
cannot be boiled down to any kind of a
coherent explanation because religious
faith is very much a product of human
culture and we can't really figure out
just what we are what our meaning is by
introspection I'm reminded of the
statements of Darwin made in one of his
notebooks which was that
the mind consciousness cannot be taken
by direct assault we cannot imagine what
we are inside by thinking about it alone
and it can't it hasn't been really
dented very well by philosophy I like to
say that most of philosophy which is a
declining and highly endangered academic
species incidentally uh consists of
failed models of how the brain works so
students going into philosophy sort of
have to learn what Descartes thought and
then after a long while while that's
wrong and what shall be our might have
thought and what Kant might have thought
or did think but they cannot go on from
that position and historical examination
of the nature of humanity to what it
really is and how we might define it so
by default the explanation of meaning of
humanity Falls to science and we are
making progress if I speak for science
ah and it's from five disciplines and
I'll take just a moment to tell you what
they are and then it'll make sense as to
why not all of Sciences whole by any
means which is developing exponentially
and in the creation of knowledge faster
and faster but from a particular set of
disciplines within science and I'm going
to name them as I approach that I'll say
you cannot fight you cannot get the
answer from astrophysicists
there are astrophysicists glad to try to
explain to you rhetorically in some way
or other that what the meaning of
humanity is and what it they're you know
studies
physics tells us about the significance
of humanity forget it they can't
possibly tell you nor just astronomers
nor just chemists nor just well my own
colleagues molecular biologists they're
too far removed from the subject to make
any sensible thing about the meaning of
human existence well what are the
disciplines and if you look at these
disciplines as I've done and I've
actually worked as a researcher in a
couple you have to know what the
contributions are of evolutionary
biology that is biology seen in a
historical context going all the way
back millions of years to the origin of
the human species and then another one
another science of course is
paleontology which segues as we come
closer to modern humanity and the
invention of agriculture and the birth
of the Neolithic period turns into
archeology so archaeology and
paleontology which are on different time
scale is the other discipline another
second discipline and a third of course
and everybody would know about this now
because it's progressing so rapidly in
so many ways is bring science and then
coming out of brain science or running
parallel to it and trading with it and
depending upon it and deriving from it
is we turn now to a more technology
subject and that is artificial
intelligence and with AI an artificial
intelligence is v robotics robotics is
so important as Hollywood has now
glommed onto knowing a good story when
they see one robotics included of course
the notion of studying the mind in
perfecting artificial intelligence
and more than that creating what the
artificial intelligence and robotics
people call whole brain emulation that
is using robots as avatars and creating
robots that are designed by design an
imitation of what we know about the
brain more and more like humans all
those five disciplines to get together
making bridges here and there are
beginning to tell us what the meaning of
humanity is a product of a grand epic
and it's a full story of humanity and
we're just beginning to just they're
drawing in clarity and let me just add
to that
why leaving out history of the whole
human species genetic as well as
cultural you have no chance whatsoever
in defining the meaning of human
existence because history that goes back
essentially to the origin of literacy
history makes no sense without
prehistory that is to say the biological
evolution that led up to the human
condition at the beginning of history
and prehistory in turn the study of our
ancestors going right back into the
animal kingdom makes no sense without
biology so we have to have a constant
building of concatenation of ideas and
information discipline to discipline
across scales of the totality of the
human population and scales of time
going back actually millions of years to
our early pre-human ancestors and then
forward to the era of cultural evolution
and then we will have the story of
humanity and then we will not ask in a
quizzical manner what is the meaning of
life what is the meaning of human
existence we will have our answers